[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
François Soudan Barack Obama qui a des
origines africaines kenyan plus
précisément a dit un jour quand il était
président des États-Unis il est dit
l'Afrique elle n'a pas besoin d'hommes
formes mais d'institutions solides il a
raison il a dit ça c'était une tournée
il était au Ghana je me souviens à Accra
il a fait cette femme sera ce qui était
reprise beaucoup après
je pense qu'il a tort parce que les deux
mangent générale pour établir des
institutions fortes il faut des hommes
forts établir les institutions
démocratiques fortes sur le papier on a
vu ce que ça a donné on l'a fait et
après les conférences de La Baule au
moment des démocratisations
début des années 2000 des institutions
tout à fait démocratiques et au des
remises en place après l'époque des
parties uniques très souvent ça il y a
eu des restaurations autoritaires après
parce que les hommes forts capables de
mener et d'installer ces institutions
par exemple de la justice qui est
quelque chose important n'était pas
présent n'était pas sur le terrain était
eux-mêmes soumis en permanence à des
remises en cause électorale etc donc il
faut les deux il faut les deux il faut
les deux comme il y a deux jambes et bon
après on se passera des hommes formés on
y est pas sur le continent pour
l'instant on en est encore aux hommes
forts on en est encore aux hommes forts
et parfois l'établissement
d'institutions fortes par ces hommes
forts à quel endroit par exemple est-ce
qu'il y a un exemple sur par exemple au
cas du Rwanda
qui est le président du Rwanda et qui a
installé des institutions solides il a
installé au niveau de
l'État de droit c'est autre chose
parlons du droit économique on le voit
là Paul Kagame
du droit des affaires parlant de la
possibilité
d'investir pour les étrangers parlons
aussi parce que ça fait partie de
l'établissement d'institution forte
l'école les formations scolaires
parlons aussi santé tout ça fait partie
de ce que j'appelle des institutions
fortes lui il l'a fait et de manière
absolument claire et de bon maintenant
c'est un homme fort c'est un homme fort
on parle justement de tout ce que vous
dites là sur la santé l'éducation on dit
que c'est la Suisse aujourd'hui de
l'Afrique donc c'est montré en exemple
aussi hein c'est montrer un exemple pour
ces résultats économiques et sociaux
absolument et une croissance très forte
incontournable vous allez à Kigali vous
verrez c'est une autre Afrique c'est la
ville la plus écologique du continent
c'est sans doute l'une des capitales des
deux trois capitales plus au monde
mais maintenant c'est vrai que c'est un
régime qui a mis le développement
économique devant le développement
démocratique et ça c'est extrêmement
difficile de mener les deux de père les
deux le front c'est quelque chose de
très difficile je crois que très peu de
gens ils sont parvenus prends le cas par
exemple de la de la Tunisie quand le
décalage
est beaucoup trop fort entre
développement économique était une
réussite à la fin de Benali et le
développement démoc à ce moment-là il
peut y avoir ce qui est arrivé c'est à
dire une révolution donc il faut faire
attention quand même à ce que l'un ne
s'éloigne pas trop de l'autre mais c'est
vrai que les fondements de la démocratie
c'est aussi l'éducation c'est aussi la
santé c'est aussi le développement
humain c'est aussi la mortalité
infantile c'est toutes ces choses-là et
puis l'éducation l'éducation c'est
quelque chose de absolument capital
alors François Soudan vous qui
connaissez parfaitement en Afrique il y
a un exemple qui correspond un peu à ce
que vous dites alors évidemment sur le
développement on pourra peut-être y
revenir mais c'est le Sénégal finalement
parce qu'il y a eu un pari qui a été
fait sur l'éducation je crois que le
tiers du budget c'est des Galets est
consacré à l'éducation des des jeunes
depuis toujours et depuis toujours
depuis Senghor c'est une mort qui avait
mis l'accent là dessus et la démocratie
depuis 74 démocratie tripartite et puis
après démocratie qui s'est ouverte avec
somme toute Caracas des alternances à
chaque fois c'est déjà la marché là
dessus le Sénégal a marché
la vitrine d'ailleurs de la partie
francophone de l'Afrique mise en valeur
ici en France etc c'est une véritable
démocratie il y a un respect en général
des droits de l'homme liberté
d'expression la liberté de la presse etc
qui sont qu'on ne retrouve pas forcément
ailleurs mais c'est aussi un pays qui
est assez propre tension on s'oriente
maintenant vers des élections
présidentielles anglaises on ignore
c'est le président Macky Sall a décidé
ou non de s'y représenter il laisse
planer une ambiguïté mon opinion c'est
que s'il a la possibilité d'y aller il
ira mais ça se passera de manière sans
doute assez compliquée alors justement
vous mettez le doigt sur quelque chose
qui est en train de se passer
actuellement en Afrique pas uniquement
au Sénégal et encore on attend de voir
parce qu'on n'en sait rien c'est ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon africaniste
les troisièmesistes c'est-à-dire les les
présidents qui veulent bien finalement
violet ou la constitution ou l'esprit de
cette Constitution ou leur propre parole
en disant qu'il ferait un troisième
mandat ce qui déplaît considérablement à
la société généralement on a on a cette
tendance en Afrique c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a quand même un recul finalement un peu
de la démocratie alors ce qui déplaît
oui à toute une partie de la société
c'est vrai ce qui nous déplait à nous
qui sommes des Occidentaux et qui
regardent cela
ce qui ne déplaît pas forcément à une
autre partie de la société c'était
évident qu'un troisième mandat en
général vaut mieux l'éviter mais
quelqu'un comme Gaga mais ou d'autres
vous expliqueront que bah après tout
c'est à la population de décider si elle
veut un troisième mandat aussi elle veut
un quatrième mandat c'est de le dire
évidemment on peut suivre ce type de
raisonnement à condition que les
élections soient réellement libres et
transparente ce qui est assez souvent
peut le cas bon
le fétichisme du troisième mandat à mon
avis doit être soumis à ce genre de
réflexion ça n'est pas quelque chose
tout ce qui est absolument obligatoire
s'arrêter au bout du deuxième mandat on
peut avoir envie de continuer son
travail à condition qu'on le fasse bien
qu'on y sont qu'on soit redevable et à
condition que cette redevabilité soit
explorée dans les urnes et validée par
les urnes dans le cas d'élection qui
soit totalement transparentes je suis
pas moi un fétichiste en disant demanda
10 ans ça suffit tu dois partir je ne
pense pas souvent ce qui essaie de
pousser le bouchon un peu plus loin
disent bah c'est moi au cas où quoi
c'est un peu la phrase d'ailleurs que
que de Gaulle ça avait dit à propos de
l'Afrique ça c'est la dérive c'est la
dérive de personnes qui se sont
absolument indispensables qui ne veulent
pas partir c'est aussi la dérive de chef
d'État a duré un déterminée qui reste
jusqu'à leur mort parce que ils ne
veulent pas partir pourquoi souvent
parce que céder le pouvoir à quelqu'un
qui a été par exemple votre dauphin est
fabriqué vous avez souvent ça se
retourne contre vous on le voit en
Mauritanie actuellement avec l'ancien
président qui a mis son dauphin qui lui
a respecté la règle des trois mandats il
a propulsé son dauphin le problème c'est
que son dauphin bon dès qu'il arrive au
pouvoir la première chose qu'il fait
c'est justement asseoir sa légitimité en
s'en prenant à celui qui l'a fait roi
son prédécesseur souvent d'ailleurs un
chef d'État qui laisse le pouvoir en
général il supporte pas longtemps
l'indépendance de son successeur qu'il a
fabriqué il veut être consulté il veut
pouvoir prendre des décisions en tout
cas être quelqu'un qui est toujours dans
le jeu donc ça se passe en général très
mal on a vu aussi on Angola avec 200 dos
Santos qui a Lorenzo
j'en ai pris à la famille de Dos Santos
pour des raisons d'ailleurs son
prédécesseur de son prédécesseur il
accusait de corruption famille et
corruption richissement etc tout ça
n'était pas faux d'ailleurs mais bon
ceux qui sont actuellement au pouvoir
qui sont encore voient ça et
réfléchissent plutôt à deux fois avant
de se dire je vais nommer un dauphin qui
me foutra la paix à moi ma famille à mes
enfants pour ma retraite et là c'est en
général ça se passe pas comme ça
finalement le discours de la Baule de
François Mitterrand pour ce qui
concernait
l'Afrique de l'Ouest sous-enfluence
entre guillemets françaises qui appelait
justement la démocratie sinon vous
n'aurez pas notre aide
ça pas été très loin cette expérience là
non ça va pas être très loin
la plupart des pays qui avaient il y a
eu des conférences nationales
qui sortait des liens au Bénin un peu
partout au Congo un petit peu partout il
y a eu des conférences nationales qui en
général se sont pas très bien passées
les parties uniques qui avaient avant
avaient je dirais un seul mérite c'est
que c'était une chape de plomb qui
étouffait les tensions
intercommunautaires les conférences
nationales ont permis à ces tensions
intercommunautaire de s'exprimer de
manière souvent conflictuelle sous le
couvert de parties qui en général
étaient des parties régionaux ou des
parties communautariste donc cette
expérience là de démocratie n'est de
l'après La Baule a souvent sombré soit
dans le capharnaüm soit parfois dans des
guerres civiles comme on a vu au Congo
Brazzaville ou ailleurs
alors François Soudan vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction de dans un
magazine qui s'appelle Jeune Afrique
magazine panafricain
[Musique]
vous êtes dans ce journal depuis fort
longtemps en 1977 si vous me permettez
de le rappeler donc vous avez une
expérience
nulle comparable sur la couverture
comment on travaille sur un continent
justement où la démocratie bah c'est pas
simple ou les pressions sont fortes
aussi bien des anciennes puissances
coloniales que des partis politiques sur
place c'est difficile de d'être un
journal panafricain dans un tel contexte
on vous dit simplement depuis 77 j'ai
conscience d'appartenir à une espèce en
voie de disparition
dans le même journal Le Monde Arabe
non c'est c'est ce journal pourquoi il
était établi à Paris d'ailleurs c'est il
a été fondé par un Tunisien il faut le
dire
très grand journaliste très grand
journaliste
vous a quitté il y a pas très longtemps
nous a quitté en 2021 mai 2021 à qui je
dois je dois beaucoup c'était qui a
fondé le son au moment des indépendants
c'est très vite installé à Paris parce
qu'on était à l'époque de la gare
d'Algérie bon il était à l'époque à
Tunis ensuite il est allé à Rome ensuite
à la fin de la gare de Jerry en 62 il
s'est installé à Paris à Paris et
pourquoi on est resté à Paris on ne sait
pas installer en Afrique pourquoi il a
décidé cela justement parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de liberté nulle part donc
c'est le seul endroit à partir duquel on
pouvait travailler et dire on pouvait
travailler dire ce que l'on ce que l'on
voulait donc on a eu connu toute une
période d'interdiction de saisie etc qui
était avant de vous dépliez vous étiez
retiré du marché on était retiré du
marché on était interdit comme ça voilà
on ne pouvait plus rentrer ou alors
saisie au numéro alors on a acheté enfin
on prenait tous les numéros là à la
police acheter les numéros de jardin qui
est marqué
mettez le feu ce qu'il voulait et on a
connu des périodes comme ça dans
beaucoup de pays on devenu des périodes
d'interdiction très dures même au Maroc
même en Algérie Algérie ça dure très
longtemps dans des pays très
dictatoriaux comme la Guinée de secours
par exemple le Zaïre de Mobutu on a eu
des périodes ce que vous disiez vous
essayez de dire de faire votre métier ça
fait plaisir et ça fait plaisir ça
dépendait c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui c'était le chef de l'État
qui décidait de nous saisir de nous
interdire c'est encore le cas un peu
moins le développement du numérique
quand même bon on ne peut plus faire
grand chose donc la censure a beaucoup
moins fort mais c'est vrai que là on a
des gros difficulté pour travailler au
Mali par exemple difficile il y a eu un
coup d'État de plusieurs coups d'État il
y a pas très longtemps il y a une gentil
militaire maintenant qui est au pouvoir
qui est très anti française bien que
nous soyons pas journal français nous
sommes en journal en français édité à
partir de Paris donc nous-mêmes à tout
ça nos envahisse spéciaux sont
systématiquement expulsés enfin c'est
très compliqué dans le pays comme ça
vous souffrez justement de ce sentiment
anti français qui aujourd'hui s'installe
un peu partout en Afrique francophone
alors qu'il y a des causes qui sont très
différentes d'ailleurs d'après vous ces
causes ne sont pas uniquement
contrairement à ce qu'on dit du
à la difficulté de l'armée française à
faire le ménage au Sahel il y a d'autres
causes qui sont les causes préexistent
profondes préexister les causes
préexister ça a démarré que le français
fasse etc la monnaie donc commune à tous
Voilà la France a payé pour le
reconnaître la manière dont elle a
décolonisé vous savez on parle pas de
sentiments anti-britannique c'est vrai
continent africain alors que l'Afrique
a coloniser la moitié du continent
anti-portugais non plus en Angola ou
Mozambique ailleurs alors pourquoi alors
il y a un sentiment anti-français sans
doute parce qu'on a mal réussi à
s'éloigner au moment où il le fallait
sans doute parce que on a fait preuve de
trop de trop d'ingérence et trop
d'arrogance
ingérence arrogance vous expliquer
simplement le cas pour la France dans
toute la période qu'on appelait la
période de la France Afrique qui
n'existe plus elle n'existe plus c'est
pour ça non je pense pas je pense pas on
est vraiment alors au bout au bout de la
queue de comète mais il n'y a plus cette
France Afrique la France Afrique telle
qu'on a connu tel que la définit une
fois de lui-même il faut être Boigny à
l'époque un mot qui vient de créer le
mot voilà c'était l'époque de Gaulle
Pompidou Giscard focard évidemment
j'étais la colonne vertébrale de ce qui
était la colonne vertébrale monsieur
system voilà du système ça continue
ensuite un peu sous Jacques Chirac il y
a déjà commencé à avoir un éloignement
et puis sous Sarkozy Hollande et
maintenant Macron on s'en est je pense
très nettement éloigné mais le
ressentiment existe toujours parce qu'on
a mal liquidé cette période des
indépendances on l'a mal explorer il
fallait partir beaucoup plus vite
d'abord le système de colonisation
française par rapport à l'anglais était
une colonisation directe ouais les
Anglais ils connaissaison indirecte bon
on se servait des chefs filales qui
gouvernait à la place du colonisateur
contestait pas le droit local nous c'est
direct c'est nos ancêtres les Gaulois
dans les écoles donc c'était vraiment un
sentiment bien sûr civilisatrice quoi
oui la culture etc donc tout ça revient
ensuite
et tout se passait qui n'a pas été
expliqué qui a mal été digéré c'est tout
cela qui revient comme des remubles
c'est pas ça qui explique la
mobilisation dans la rue anti-française
non parce que il y a eu le Mali il y a
eu l'opération servale qui est une
réussite au début et ensuite je dirais
pas un échec mais en tout cas on est en
rond sur R4 finissait par tourner en
rond et il y a eu après la propagande
russe qui est arrivée c'est cette
propagande là qui a donné je dirais un
axe assez précis à ce sentiment
anti-français qu'il a alimenté de
manière assez inquiétante pour les
Français elle est aussi elle est en
péril je dirais l'influence française à
votre avis dans une certaine mesure oui
il faut vraiment que la France arrive à
repenser ses relations avec l'Afrique de
manière beaucoup plus professionnelle
manière beaucoup moins sentimentale il
faut être professionnel il faut
enlever tout cet aspect affectif dans
les relations que le
l'Africains ne veulent plus de cet
aspect effectivement le plus il n'en
veulent plus et il faut que Emmanuel
Macron fasse très attention il ne peut
pas s'empêcher de mettre cette affaire
parfois sur la table il veut pas
s'empêcher bon vous savez quand il était
à Ouagadougou il l'a fait alors 2017 il
était au pouvoir depuis peu de temps il
va à Ouagadougou du Burkina
Kaboré en disant il est parti à rallumer
la clim voilà c'est ça effectivement il
y a un discours il y a le président
Kaboré qui est le président à l'époque
du Burkina et qui se lève parce que un
propos de Macron lui déplaît un petit
peu et Macron lance ça en disant il est
parti allumer la climatisation ce qui
est quand même il s'exprime devant les
étudiants en plus à l'époque s'exprime
le premier monde et merveilles
d'ailleurs à ce problème on émerveille
il énormément de choses il aussi sur les
visas etc c'est sûr cela les premiers
beaucoup de choses qui n'ont pas été
suivi des faits alors après on a essayé
de rattraper le coup et que le sommet de
Montpellier ici que c'est passé en
France alors là c'était avec les
sociétés civile c'était uniquement avec
la société de chef d'État voilà
uniquement avec la société civile le
problème c'est que c'est avec une une
élite
dirigée par des gens très bien qu'en
acquis par les gens très bien quand même
chez le bébé comme celui de ma machine
bien comme felwinsart etc ce sont des
personnes intellectuelles des
intellectuels que l'on met ici en valeur
etc mais qui sont des gens qui sont
écoutés par une une infime fraction de
la population africaine alors que les
Russes et je puis dire où le sentiment
anti français utilisé par les Russes
mais en première ligne des influenceurs
qui eux tapent en dessous de la ceinture
et donc parle directement je passe par
les réseaux sociaux passe pas les
réseaux sociaux il y a beaucoup
d'insultes il y a des fake news
ça fait appel à un certain nombre de
sentiments xénophobes etc donc ça
fonctionne je dirais beaucoup mieux et
ça mobilise des centaines de milliers de
personnes les centaines de milliers de
personnes face à cela la France fait
quoi elle essaye de contre-attaquer au
niveau des réseaux sociaux parce qu'on
s'est dit bon on a un problème on ne
peut pas utiliser les mêmes armes les
Français ne peuvent pas la
désinformation les fake news c'est pas
possible donc le c'est une guerre
asymétrique en fait oui d'accord ouais
et les Russes qui ont fait de l'Afrique
un second front après celui de l'Ukraine
il suffit de voir le vote à l'ONU il est
tourné de Monsieur lavrof elle est
déclarations qui fait à Bamako il
propose l'aide sécurité de la Russie non
seulement au Mali où elle existe déjà en
Centrafrique de soja mais aussi au
Burkina Faso mais aussi à la Guinée mais
aussi à tous les pays menacés par
exemple nous on est prêts à vous aider
difficile pour la France et ça c'est une
période compliquée alors vous avez
interviewé quasiment toute la planète
enfin toutes les
chefs d'État de gouvernement africaine
de l'Afrique
quelles sont ceux qui vous ont le plus
impressionné ou marqué ce qui est pas
tout à fait la même chose d'ailleurs
c'est une bonne question
au niveau de l'agilité intellectuelle et
de la difficulté à le faire parler
à le contredire c'est pour Kagame un
contestablement j'ai le président
rwandais j'ai même fait un livre
interview avec lui
il est à la fois très intéressant et
très très difficile à piéger c'est ah
oui personnage
une agilité intellectuelle assez
remarquable et assez redoutable bref
j'avais de bonnes interviews avec
Idriss Déby père celui qui est donc le
président du Tchad président du Tchad
qui est mort au combat
et son fils a succédé
[Musique]
résultat une armurerie à celle ouvert la
Libye après la chute de Kadhafi au monde
s'est servi avec des centaines de
milliers d'armes toutes ces armes ont
pris ensuite bouffé direction du sud les
stocks de Kadhafi Kadhafi a acheté des
armes par millions de tonnes pendant il
a fait ça pendant 30 ans donc c'était
voilà il avait des désarçonneaux énormes
qui ont tous été tes pieds et qui ont
tous servi ensuite au terroristes au
djihadistes au narcotrafiquants à tout
le monde et tous les gens qui se
baladent actuellement toutes ces groupes
à travers le Sahel de du Mali jusque à
la Somalie l'armement pour beaucoup
vient
des stocks et bien qui ont été pillés
intégralement à cette époque on dit
beaucoup que la Kadhafi
a provoqué une espèce de no man's land
qui s'appelle la Libye parce que la
Libye n'a jamais été vraiment un état
c'était
un territoire tenu par un homme mais qui
n'avait aucune idée
je dirais émis gravement en péril
d'ailleurs d'une certaine façon les
intérêts français aussi parce que c'est
la France qui a provoqué avec les
Britanniques la chute de Kadhafi mais
finalement les intérêts français au-delà
au Sahel ont été ont été affectés par ça
oui oui non tout à fait Kadhafi est un
personnage nous sommes pas rendu compte
à quel point son pouvoir reposer c'est
en fait sur un pouvoir de tribu c'est ça
donc c'était un état trival avec des
alliances entre tribus en général bon
avec un fioul qui était l'argent entre
eux et on s'est rendu compte à quel
point c'était comme ça les Français bon
on connaît la politique française
parce que vous appelez François Soudan
qui est le nom d'un des États de
l'Afrique maintenant il y en a deux
d'ailleurs Soudan il y a le Soudan du
Sud aussi
mais vous êtes français pourquoi cette
attachement à l'Afrique alors le nom est
d'origine belge
Wallonie vallonie moi je suis français
mais vous êtes du Nord d'ailleurs
de la France pourquoi cette attachement
en Afrique
c'est un petit peu un hasard j'ai fait
mon service militaire à l'époque parce
qu'appelait la coopération vous avez
connu ça cette opération militaire
coopération tout court
voilà j'étais enseignant et donc j'ai
été enseignant dans ce qui s'appelait
encore c'est tout à fait à la fin le DAO
mai d'accord ça c'est le Bénin
donc c'est à ce moment-là qui est venu
mon intérêt pour le continent que j'ai
continué ensuite à suivre assidûment
quand j'étais à l'école Jean isolive
quand j'étais à Sciences Po j'ai
continué à travailler sur l'Afrique
d'accord c'est et puis bon à la fin j'ai
postulé à différents emplois première
répondre a été a été Béchir maniabète je
suis arrivé comme ça c'est très simple
et vous n'avez jamais quitté alors du
coup cet amour de l'Afrique parce que
j'imagine qu'il y a un amour derrière ça
quand même c'est pas uniquement
politique c'est aussi
culturel c'est aussi je suis oui c'est
culturel aussi moi j'ai mon épouse est
africaine d'accord
elle est congolaise d'ailleurs ministre
dans le gouvernement de Denis
Sassou-Nguesso
ce qui d'ailleurs
signifié que âge en Afrique je j'ai
décidé je l'ai plus écrire sur le Congo
Brazzaville d'accord
donc l'attention est forcément culturel
puisque mes enfants l'Adobe nationalité
d'accord ok vous avez un livre de
littérature africaine que vous appréciez
tout particulièrement
les livres de Kuruma d'Amadou Kourouma
le vote des bêtes sauvages d'accord ok
bien connu un écrivain un écrivain
ivoirien
ivoirien malheureusement
je pense un des meilleurs livres le
personnage qui le décrit le chef d'État
c'est il y a des mains l'ancien
président du Togo et l'un des archétypes
de la France a truc que bosser un
personnage extrêmement truculant donc
j'ai bien connu il y a des masses on
peut y aller à l'époque j'ai retrouvé
chez gruma mais écrit de manière sublime
une musique que vous aimez
sur le continent indépendance Chacha je
crois que c'était indépendance tchatcha
ça a été le oui c'est chaque fois que
j'entends ça
je me retrouve replonger plonger parce
que j'ai pas connu cette époque dans les
années 60 c'est le tous les rêves de
l'indépendance de l'Afrique d'accord
celle de la création de
l'Union africaine
pour le panafricanisme le panafricanisme
mais dans tout ce qu'il y avait de
d'humaniste derrière c'était pas un
panafricanisme agressif vis-à-vis
d'Occident comme on a actuellement c'est
quoi le panafricanisme le panafricadisme
c'est une de cette époque c'est une idée
qui vient d'ailleurs pour beaucoup des
de Marcus gravé des Américains des Noirs
américains de l'époque qui préconisait
le retour au continent le retour racine
etc une Afrique unie d'une Afrique sans
frontières puisque les frontières comme
chacun sait des définir la conférence de
Berlin par le colonisateur en 1885 donc
et qui ne forment qu'un seul et même
pays on a lui-même rêve à un moment avec
l'Europe non c'est ça mais aujourd'hui
ce pas d'africanisme ça veut pas dire
tout à fait la même chose parce que
c'est un argument qui est servi aussi
c'est maintenant un argument de combat
intellectuel culturel de revendications
souverainiste
qui est anti-européen aussi antioxydant
parfois dévoyé de manière antioxydante
ça vous fait peur ça c'est pas
uniquement anti français c'est
antioxydantal effectivement
anti-oénue etc je pense que c'est une
triste c'est une très mauvaise voie
orientation c'est une voie de repli sur
soi du continent
on est la mondialisation personne n'y
échappe il y a des choses négatives il
faut se battre et des choses positives
se battre pour que l'Afrique soit ancrée
dans la mondialisation et nous notre
combat Jeune Afrique on a eu un premier
combat c'était pour les indépendances
des colonisation donc deuxième combat
c'était pour la fin des parties uniques
le troisième combat c'était
l'indépendance économique maintenant le
quatrième fois qu'on a maintenant
c'est pour ancrer l'Afrique dans la
mondialisation qu'elle soit réellement
prise en compte le panafricanisme de
combat dont on parle les militants va
donc contre ça vous êtes optimiste
néanmoins pour ce continent oui bien sûr
bien sûr il y a une forme de résilience
extraordinaire en Afrique et une forme
de créativité et puis il n'y a pas que
l'Afrique qui l'Afrique la carte de la
crise de l'Afrique est trompeuse et il y
a toute une partie de l'Afrique il y a
beaucoup d'Afrique avec un S parce qu'il
y a 54 Afrique en fait évidemment il
fonctionne très bien merci François
Soudan merci Yves
[Musique]